[Music]
and kid vs. pro news oh I hope this is
about fighting we do yeah
okay kid you're [ __ ] now okay
submitted by Fernando but a penis from
the penis California no no Peter no
penis rule no this mean be bad I mean
like that's how we call the fetus that
rhymed said Nanda Rodriguez America's
California yeah a 12 year old girl
dominates a pro fighter twice her age an
amazing mama debut Oh a 12 year old girl
12 nominates
a professional mama fighter 24 year old
hey why did you - ah emanating from my
mama mama ma this course I'm Owen but
there's no no Angus I'm making the sound
of its letter and ma ma ma ma
I don't even auto register this is as
far as they they don't watch the video
is their video we got a seat I like how
you assumed correctly I was about to ask
you like how do you know if you are like
this without a video it's [ __ ] what
it is what works is that we landed on
the moon what was the video we don't
have up10tion [ __ ] Obama punched a bad
guy in the face but what's the video it
never happened up one small leap for man
ah well one small jump - man what where
one small step for man one giant leap
erm and for mr. Wilson with a whip and
the 12 year old Japanese spider
my name is maja Shimizu she defeated 24
year-old Momoko Yamazaki so mama
the 12 year olds she uploaded a couple
training video clips before the fight so
that's what you're gonna see first and
then it's going to go into the fight and
there wasn't like really good coverage
so excuse the values that good coverage
my eyes know
anime they better be playing rocky music
for the training sequence are you so
there's gonna be no sound this is the
top rope ready 12 year old yeah I heard
that almost in this hunt
can we add sound effects somebody do
something over watch I might be good at
already I could pay attention and do as
a varying in the small K and then pick a
Penta Penta content
what the [ __ ] you guys yeah be all time
[Laughter]
god damn blue thanks man
Ravinder this is my raw and I my binary
b2 here with the top your hangar where
the tiger is the cream and underwear
survival which means Chinese nose been
there are were you killed our movie
version okay yeah that's crazy
twelve years old so when this fight was
first announced there was a lot of
people saying how is this even high
because Japanese girls when the 24th are
still look like they're 12 you know so
they just kind of evened up I almost
guarantee after that match that 24 year
old got shunned nice so you like to give
me but 12 year old you get out of well
she actually got beat by all technique
though yeah like she what she wasn't our
muscle she wasn't like out aggressed
is that even a word it was just all
technique she's just good so when this
fight was announced uh Sam
they said that it would be a mature
ruled which my that idea yeah which
means that the fighters would have
headgear and strikes to the head on the
ground were prohibited but still those
huge backlash so here's some of the
backlash I move mr. Sakamoto reporting
live from was a mega challenge Jeff what
in the world I can't imagine being a
grown adult accepting a fight with a
child and the promoter should be rung up
on child abuse
right on promoter ought to be hung by
his deep jewels he whose mic chiapetta
I've never heard of him
I don't know that's kind of period maybe
he's at mama
tighter
[Music]
she's 12 years old this is a terrible
terrible idea how is it even legal
because Paul in Japan yeah
and this is an exact measurement but
then are they what's a backlash after
she won or was it me who had a fight
happen did so after the fight did
everyone go
oh this is why they let her fight
because she's a phenom mmm no I didn't
really see um much response after the
fact but it was just reported though
like before the fight there was a lot of
people against it because she's a child
that's like amateur rules there's
headgear yeah but still people still
like she's been like how does an adult
you know there's like no [ __ ] age
thing when you even when you do like
martial arts tournaments they do it by
weight and height weight they do my
weight concert yeah they did it with a
95 95 pound weight class oh so they're
in the same weight class minimum weight
division yeah oh I don't know how I feel
about this because guess she is a child
but she's a trained child and she
probably beat every frickin child and
her oh but it's 12 and 24 I guess that's
business
yeah all thinking like 12 and 16 I'm
tripping right now all right Joseph she
probably swept her everyone that's her
age already and everyone probably up to
18 and she needs more D colleges because
that's the same story with Vitor Belfort
same story with Wanderlei Silva in
fighting since they were like 13 14 and
just kicked adult asses they're just
done so he left Brazil to go find other
people to fight I already beat everybody
up in my country nobody else to beat up
thank you no I'm an eight-way why do you
know what at what age he started
fighting I'm not sure I don't win tender
age of three months her mom started
slapping her in a fix hon oh yeah I do
know that Yamazaki was twenty four year
old she is a professional fighter who
now has a 2/4 career record she sucks
she lost four times 21 times yeah well
she's young oh no 24th out there yeah
that's right
and a 12 year old this is her amateur M
amazing
you yeah the 24 year old maybe she
should really fighting if you lost to a
12 year old and your records are already
looking pretty bad I'm not saying that a
fight of myself understands December who
likes watching the sport but at that age
when you're that young and you don't
show promise it might not be a good idea
she's going backwards
she's a pro fighter losing an amateur
fight yeah like it does it does ever
work that way yeah if you're Pro like if
we're in the NBA and you go play some
college basketball or a high school
players you're gonna [ __ ] beat their
ass yeah does it make any sense for a
pro to go an amateur and they get to ask
it
yeah I don't know it's a sport so once
it's got that label of it for um
fighting is no longer fighting to me
like it's not just the foot it's
aggressive but it's not a form of
violence and aggression in that way
it's kind of like people can play
basketball really aggressively we've
seen people play ping-pong
very aggressive yeah right but then like
people don't get really hurt from it but
the sport here it just it's a striking
sport so you get hit in the potential
danger I guess that's why they don't
like the whole child versus adult thing
yeah it makes sense this is great but
I'd be seeing like 12 year olds do some
crazy extreme sports and that [ __ ] looks
more dangerous than fighting to me like
when I see kids like riding motorcycles
and doing flips and ramps and going
downhill really really fast I'm just
like dude that [ __ ] that [ __ ] looks
scarier than fighting I think the reason
why people might get matter whatever is
fighting the purpose of fighting is to
hurt each other yeah so it's not like
the purpose is do a backflip it's how
many times can I put my fist on this
prison space separate two they have that
like punch count leg kick counts like
they actually know okay after this fight
you punch them 233 times this prison
punch 175 times so it's a sport of how
much can you inflict damage or take out
a person yeah that's why I don't want
children to fail that [ __ ] that's a cat
abuse
Knight is a shrink I kind of know which
is a tunnel between 24 12 through the 12
year old looks like a six year old
yeah that's a lekha so sad why because
it looks like she's beating up a baby
but the baby beat her up
how the [ __ ] you gonna let a baby beat
your ass up oh man she's probably gonna
go seppuku now he's older by Imogene
sister
you know have you guys seen those videos
of people who think that they could do
to do this martial arts and they get
their ass beat there's like this one
very famous one of a kind I guess they
call him called our soccer mom but she
watched Ronda Rousey fight it's got
really hike to do it and so she entered
a match without any training oh my god I
know he got obliterated like this woman
fell asleep like knocked out I she just
why didn't she train I think she just
forgot like one small difference that
Ronda Rousey is an Olympian yes I think
that's probably what wow you know how
she approached the lady - if you watch
the video she served country like this
oh my god just trying to do some cheek
window huh my elbows are [ __ ] pop you
should open like this and its really
blinds up like she just [ __ ] cracks
her and it was just game over
Oh Ronda Rousey her mother out a fighter
crack the [ __ ] out of her face did I
ever tell you guys why people fought
like this back in a day no I found out
why was a bare-knuckle boxing technique
this one's you know these like
old-school boxes they're like this right
yeah so um you don't want to hurt your
hands and they're fighting bare knuckle
and all that stuff what's going to
happen to your career if you keep
hitting knuckle to face and um what so
when they struck they struck and jabbed
with like the palm well I guess or they
did dip think is not the number no no
they they strip the face with the palm
so that's why they're in this position
and then they're going like that or
jabbing the beer yeah I was like oh [ __ ]
because it looked [ __ ] weird like why
is there pictures of all these
old-school boxers in this position
nickname I don't know when it changed
but that it came from bare-knuckle
boxing where in the beginning they would
fight it they're not trying to make
contact with the knuckle to the face
they're just hitting with the palm and
stuff like that yeah that's interesting
I thought so fYI hey guys I hope you
enjoyed that episode of just getting
news and if you guys want to share a
story there's a link down in the
description box below where you can
submit your story if you guys want to
watch more episodes click right up here
[Music]